democrats and the media grow
increasingly rabid about new
anti-coveted measures even though
americans are
adults i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is brought to you
by expressvpn make sure that you protect
your internet use expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment here is your reminder if you
are using
one of the giant cell phone providers
who are spending too much money this is
why you should be using pure talk usa
take a look at that cell phone bill
if you're verizon a t or t-mobile you're
paying too much pure talk can save your
family over 800
per year yep that same great coverage
because pure talk's on the exact same
network as one of the big three but at a
fraction of the price
and switching is as easy as switching
out your sim card you can keep your
phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids plus right now
unlimited talk text six gigs of data for
just 30 bucks a month and
if you go over on the data they're not
going to charge you for it there is a
reason bears talk is the highest rated
wireless company by consumer affairs why
they are the preferred wireless partner
of amac again there is no reason you
should be spending all that much money
on your cell phone bell given the fact
that a lot of it is going to overhead
and advertising instead you should just
be using pure talk usa and getting
exactly what you need which is what
they're going to give you
from your cell phone sal pound 250 say
ben shapiro save an additional 50
off your very first month that is pound
250 say ben shapiro to get started that
is pound two five zero say my name ben
shapiro to get started
with my friends over at pure talk usa
alrighty so panic panic
everybody panic we have to panic it's
very important that we panic the
headlines today betray nothing but panic
panic panic
everywhere oh okay here is the thing
there's not really a great reason to
panic so the headline over at drudge
report which has basically just become
the huffington post at this point
giant headlines pique covid now peak
covid now okay is it really pete covered
now because when i think
of pete covett i think how many people
are dying of covid right
this is one of the things that has
driven me nuts for the past several
months case
counts don't matter hospitalizations and
deaths
matter even if hospitalizations get
disconnected from deaths
hospitalizations don't matter as much
as deaths do okay so it used to be the
case counts were
really really closely tied to death rate
now thanks to the vaccine that has been
wildly disconnected to the point where
90 of all americans above the age of 65
are now vaccinated against covenant 19
and 70 of all americans above the age of
eighteen
are vaccinated against copenhagen and
that is not including all of the people
who didn't get vaccinated who already
had covered nineteen who probably have
natural antibodies or t-cell memory
which means that in all likelihood you
are looking at an adult population in
the united states above the age of 18
in excess of at least 75 maybe 80
percent of all of those people
who already have some level of immunity
to covet 19.
a very shrinking diminishing percentage
of the population is still highly
vulnerable to covert 19
which is why you have seen this wild
disconnect between the case rates
and the death rates we are also seeing
an increasing disconnect between
hospitalization rates
and death rates why well because at the
very beginning of the pandemic
everybody who went to the hospital was
80 years old and had three pre-existing
conditions
now a lot of the people who are going to
the hospital are 25 and have one
pre-existing condition and are staying
in the hospital for say five or six days
and then getting out as opposed to
staying for two weeks and then dying and
you can see this
in the death rates because who cares
about getting diagnosed with kovid if
you end up with a mild cold
i'm seeing sheer panic out there today
because wow lindsey graham
announced that he had a breakthrough
case of covenant now he's going to
self-quarantine
for 10 days okay so first of all
i am not even sure that it's worth
quarantining
if you have covet at this point like
it's it's so widespread
that i'm not even sure like on a public
health level whether quarantining is
actually going to slow the spread
in any significant like i get it i get
you're supposed to quarantine if you
have covet i do
i understand i understand why they're
telling you to do this because there's
so many unvaccinated people out there
but if lindsey graham is dealing with a
lot of vaccinated people every day
then really this should not be like of
massive concern
in the same way that many people go to
the office when they have a cold many
people go to the office when they are
feeling mildly ill
if kovid is now degraded to the level of
a mild illness i don't understand
why everybody on earth is supposed to be
freaking out that lindsey graham got a
breakthrough case of covey that has
resulted in the sniffles
according to the daily wire lindsey
graham announced on monday afternoon he
tested positive for cobia 19 and started
experiencing symptoms
on saturday he said he started having
flu-like symptoms saturday night he went
to the doctor
he said i feel like i have a sinus
infection at present i have mild
symptoms i'll be quarantining for 10
days
okay why is that even a public health
story i don't understand
being diagnosed with basically very very
mild illness
is not a public health emergency and so
when you see people freaking out about
case rates
it makes no sense it is just alarmism of
the highest order
so when you have cnbc reporting cdc says
seven-day average of daily us coveted
cases surpassed peak
seen last summer yes but last summer we
were seeing like
way more death i'm looking at us covert
death rates right now
okay the seven day rolling average
according to the new york times remains
at 362.
which is basically where it was about a
month ago
if you want to look at the height of the
pandemic or even if you want to look
last summer
at the height of the pandemic last
summer you were looking at seven day
rolling averages that were at least
twice
what you are seeing right now in terms
of death rates okay so the the
the sort of insane panic that is being
trotted out there
it really is wild and by the way there
is some countervailing data to suggest
that perhaps the daily averaging coveted
cases might be going down actually
according to cnbc itself u.s covet cases
based on a seven-day moving average
reached 72
790 on friday according to data compiled
by the cdc
that's higher than the peak in average
daily cases seen last summer when the
country was reporting
about 68 700 new cases per day the daily
average in coveted cases however has
since
dropped falling to 68 326 new cases per
day on saturday and 63
250 new cases per day on sunday
according to the agency now
there are some data from johns hopkins
that suggest the opposite
they show a continued increase in the
seven day average to nearly 80 000 new
cases per day
as of sunday but again case rates don't
matter by the way you know who's saying
case rates don't matter anymore
the biden administration the biden
administration called up cnn and they
said why are you reporting the case
numbers as opposed to the
hospitalization and death numbers
precisely precisely that's what we
should be reporting
again the the kind of focus in on how
dumb americans are and how terrible we
all and then
oh the unvaccinated they're all gonna 70
plus percent of americans are now
overtly vaccinated above the age of 18.
many more have already gotten natural
immunity through having covid
90 of all people in the 65 plus age
group are vaccinated that is a massive
success story
if anybody had the brains to notice it
and you know what's going to happen with
the delta variant
it is going to spike and then it is
going to wane and you know why i say
that's going to happen
because it has happened in all the
countries it is happening everywhere
it happened in the uk it happened in the
netherlands and yet the panic is just
outsized right everybody everybody panic
so leanna wen who just
is on tv every day because she gets to
promote panic
she said to yahoo news quote the single
biggest mistake the biden administration
made during this entire pandemic
response and i would argue in the entire
biden presidency
was back in may when the cdc said that
vaccinated people can take off their
mask but did not have proof of
vaccination attached to it
as a result people understood the
pandemic to be over them over them they
unvaccinated began behaving like they
were vaccinated
um first of all this is so utterly and
wildly
not related to reality the unvaccinated
largely were always acting as though the
pandemic was over that's why they were
unvaccinated
it wasn't like the unvaccinated waited
for joe biden to say vaccinated you can
unmask the one hey
now i can unmask too this has been
lyanna wins
you know bugaboo for a long time here
she thinks the mask mandates are the be
all end all as we will explore mass
mandates are in fact not the be all end
all mass mandates have been wildly
ineffective
by the available data that we have that
doesn't mean that all masking is
ineffective it means
mass mandates pushed top down by the
government have been extremely
ineffective okay she says what did we
see we saw exactly what i and many
public health experts predicted at the
time
the honor code did not work surges have
happened because of unvaccinated
individuals
now with the delta variant restrictions
are coming back except nobody's
listening anymore okay but
that that's not people weren't listening
in the first place like does she know
anyone who's unvaccinated seriously
has like has liana wen talked to anyone
who was unvaccinated
has she spent any time in the red states
that she likes to crap all over
i have serious doubts because that's not
how people were behaving in the first
place
people who are unvaccinated are
significantly less worried about the
virus than people who are vaccinated
unmasking the vaccinated had zero impact
on unmasking the unvaccinated
this is just madness and she said
president biden absolutely declared
a victory too soon right victories there
will be no more victory and biden
himself
has now drunk from this well i the only
rationale
politically this is unbelievably stupid
politically what joe biden
and biden administration are doing right
now is incredibly dumb because all they
have to do is wait about three weeks
and then delta will will drop i'm just
telling you right now
this is not just me saying this all
right my carry of johns hopkins
university is saying this scott gottlieb
from the fda is saying this
pretty much all the scientists agree
looking at the uk which had a wave that
looked very much like this one and the
netherlands which had a wave that looked
very much like this one
there will be a drop in terms of the
daily case rates in the united states
all joe biden has to do is say go get
back like this is a very
easy message if you're vaccinated you're
pretty much safe from the virus if
you're unvaccinated
most by by all available data the best
chance is that you will get somewhere
between mildly and moderately ill
a small percentage of you will get
severely ill and an even smaller
percentage of you will die but
it's a larger percentage than if you got
vaccinated so you probably should get
vaccinated right that is the case for
getting vaccinated now you're an adult
go live your life
and if you get covered because you
didn't get vaccinated and if
you get a serious case of covet that
really it's your decision you're an
adult
we're relying on you to make your own
decisions now this would be very easy
for joe biden to do and then it's off
his plate i mean just politically
speaking first of all that would be a
better
public health message but put aside the
public health messaging of it
it would get it off this plate
politically because then it would be on
individual americans to decide
whether or not they wanted to protect
themselves okay but joe biden can't do
that because the unspoken goal
of the entire democratic party and the
entire media for a year has been zero
coveted
zero covet is never going to happen and
the reason
that democrats and the media bought into
zero covet is because it gave them
ultimate control over your life
if they set the goal at zero coveted and
zero covert is never going to happen
but in order to achieve the utopia of
zero covid they get to maintain control
that is a feature not a bug that is a
good thing more eviction moratoria
the cdc today by the way issued guidance
that allowed joe biden the excuse
of continuing to expel migrants who are
crossing the southern border illegally
so there was a rule that was put in
place by the trump administration that
allowed for quick expulsion of illegal
immigrants who tested positive for covet
the cdc came in the body administration
planned to throw that out
the cdc came in and they trumped it the
cdc is a bureaucratic
organization they don't have plenary
power over immigration but
now they do because the magic of public
health emergencies like any other
emergency is it gives inordinate power
to small groups of unelected bureaucrats
democrats
are very very happy about this so the
emergency mentality
must the emergency mentality will
continue until morale improves
that is the basic strategy here and joe
biden apparently is all in this is so
dumb politically here is joe biden
saying get ready for more restrictions
coming up more
restrictions because in all probability
by the way we had a good day yesterday
almost a million people got vaccinated
about half a million of those people for
the first time after the second shot
and so i'm hopeful that people are
beginning to realize how essential it is
okay but i i also really enjoy how the
public health officials who have
completely botched
the public messaging with regard to
vaccination are now taking credit for
more people vaccinating you know why
more people
are vaccinating because more people are
scared of covid end of story
which demonstrates once again adults do
risk allocation
all the time they do risk reward
allocation all the damn time
they don't require daughtering old fools
like joe biden to force them to do it
in gensake she said well you know we're
probably not going to do more shutdowns
but
i'm not going to say that anything is
off the table at this point here's jen
saki from the white house yesterday
we've been clear we're not going back to
the shutdowns of march of 2020.
we are not going back to the economy
shutting down we've made too much
progress
too many people are vaccinated there's
been too much progress on the economic
front
but again he has said from the beginning
that we are going to be guided by the
science guided by our public health
experts and we're not going to take
options off the table what they may
recommend
okay so this is just um yeah this is
this is wild
the whole point here is that elected
officials have to balance all of the
competing interests
from the economy to freedom but now
there she is basically just saying well
we'll let dr fauci and rochelle bolenski
decide which is
a very very bad idea and by the way it
is resulting
in dramatically decreased poll numbers
for joe biden and kamala harris on a
political level you know keep going
with this guys really let's see how it
works out for you we'll get to that in
one second first
there are a thousand reasons why
protecting my home matters to me i mean
i have three major reasons they are all
under the age
of eight yeah i want to make sure that i
know what's going on in my house because
i want to know what's going on with my
kids i want to know who's stopping by
the front door
i want to know everything that's going
on in my property at all times this is
why i have ring devices on my house
on the inside and the outside of my
house ring has a special offer right now
go to ring.com forward slash ben it is
the perfect way to start your ring
experience with ring's home security
system when anyone stops by or you send
something going on
outdoors around the house you know ring
has every corner of your home covered
one of the best benefits you install the
products yourself the process is
hassle free your whole home is protected
with easy to install indoor and
outdoor cams and get this the cams work
seamlessly with ring alarm you can see
what's happening from anywhere all in
one very simple app
it's never been more important to have a
reliable home security system i'm
pleased
my family and i can keep an eye on
everything going on anywhere
anytime protect your home anytime from
anywhere with ring
alarm go to ring.com ben for a special
offer on a ring alarm security kit today
you can build the system that's right
for your home have it up and running
in just minutes that's ring.com once
more ring.com
ben alrighty so all of this is just not
only bad policy it is terrible politics
there is a reason
that opinion polls are showing that
americans are really pessimistic right
now and it's because if you set a goal
like zero covid and it is unreachable
and then you don't reach it and then the
media freak out
every time everybody gets a cold people
are going to get very pessimistic
very quickly right now kamala harris's
numbers
are really really bad her unpopularity
is at 49
her popularity hovers about 45 according
to a
yougov america poll she's particularly
unpoppable according to economist in new
gov with younger voters only 36
of people aged 18 to 29 view her
favorably
joe biden apparently is moving in the
wrong direction a new rasmussen reports
poll shows at least 52 percent of likely
voters
now disapprove of joe biden's work in
the white house 42 percent said they
strongly disapprove only 26
say they strongly approve of joe biden's
presidency
and even if you see polls that are more
positive providing they're way worse
than they were just a few weeks ago when
it comes to optimism and pessimism about
the country
people are way more pessimistic than
they were just a few months ago one of
the reasons is because of the alarmist
idiocy being pushed
by the media i mean it is an amazing
thing that now you are seeing officials
from the white house who are chiding the
media
for their coverage of covid because the
media and the democratic party they are
the same
they are a unity okay all the media at
this essentia at this point basically
are a loudspeaker for whatever the white
house wants them to be
and so when when the white house are
chatting to me you guys are too panicked
stop with the panic already
this demonstrates how far the media have
gone in pursuit
of the panic okay so because of this
panic which again is rooted in uh
misunderstanding
of the difference in cases and deaths
it's rooted in a misunderstanding of the
trajectory of the delta variant which
again we have already seen in the uk
we've already seen in the netherlands
because it is rooted in a basic
misunderstanding
of the of the possibility of how people
actually spread this thing from
vaccinated to unvaccinated the media
been covering it like
if you're vaccinated you are just as
likely to pass this thing as if you are
unvaccinated like all of this
these are bad headlines and bad data
being pushed forward by the media
and many of the people responsible for
this bad
data frankly are members of the public
health establishment the fouchus and
malenski's
of the world this has resulted in some
incredibly dumb public health
recommendations
so for example you've heard a lot about
masking up so san francisco mayor london
breed declared yesterday that everybody
in san francisco vaccinated and
unvaccinated needs to mask
up which is totally crazy okay i'm
looking
right now at the san francisco covid
raids
san francisco covet cases right now
the their cases are up right there
they're up to about
a thousand cases a day the san francisco
rolling death rate
august 1 2021 their rolling death rate
seven day average
zero zero again san francisco
is masking up again and their seven day
rolling average on deaths
is currently zero okay the population of
san francisco
is somewhere in the neighborhood of 900
000 people
okay this is madness of course now bill
de blasio didn't go quite as far he said
he was going to reject an indoor mask
mandate
for the vaccinated but he then came out
and said he wanted to recommend that
everybody wear masks in indoor settings
even if you're vaccinated which of
course
does not make a lot of sense the whole
point here is that if you're telling the
vaccinated to mask up
you're actually telling people that the
vaccines are not effective
unfortunately that is the message that
people are taking away and that is the
wrong message
vaccines are extremely effective because
what vaccines are designed to do is
prevent you from the dead
they're you are not supposed to die if
you get the vaccine they're really good
at this
they're not as good at preventing you
from giving a mild cold to somebody else
vaccinated or
transmitting to somebody who's
unvaccinated then they get really sick
that's why you're an adult if you want a
vaccine go get a vaccine today they're
available
everywhere really you can't run down the
street now without running past some
place
that is offering a vaccine if you want
the vaccine go get the vaccine
if you don't then bear the consequences
but here's bill de blasio telling the
vaccinated maybe they should consider
masking up
we want to strongly recommend that
people wear masks
in indoor settings even if you're
vaccinated
now this is particularly true of course
if you might be around
anyone unvaccinated if you don't know
the people you're around if you're not
sure if they're vaccinated not or if you
know some are unvaccinated
absolutely crucial to wear a mask uh
even if you are vaccinated okay now you
notice that he's holding a cloth face
mask correct
and this is the go-to is the cloth face
mask now there's been a lot of debate in
public health circles about just how
effective the cloth face masks are
there are some studies that suggest that
these are these are lab studies these
are not real world studies that suggest
that there may be some mild
effectiveness to class face masks
n95 seem to be significantly more
effective but you're supposed to
actually get a new n95 every day with
pretty much no one does
okay the the the real world studies i'm
asking are are somewhat conflicting
right to just be straight with you
there's some studies that suggest a
level of
efficacy those tend to be lab studies
where it says that
a barrier is better than nothing fair
enough and then there's some real world
studies which suggest that
masking is not quite as effective as
people think it is because people tend
to mess around with it because there are
air pockets but people will
will move their mask they'll take a
dirty mess put it in their pocket put it
back on their face
and all the rest of that sort of thing
so the record is missed
is mixed one thing that is indubitably
true
and obviously true is that mass mandates
have had no real impact
okay let's begin in sweden okay right
now according to rt.com
mask-free sweden nears zero daily covet
deaths as cheap
chief epidemiologist warns against
far-reaching conclusions against the
delta strain
remember sweden was ripped up and down
for its approach to covet which was
basically protect the the people who are
most vulnerable let everybody else go
live their life there was no mass
mandate in kovad
there hasn't been since like july since
last july
uh or or rather uh sweden dropped its
last remaining they had very mild mascot
recommendations for like
public transport but they dropped that
on july 1st
they supported some social distancing
measures but sweden was very wide open
from the beginning
of the pandemic and right now sweden is
experiencing
pretty much zero covet death on a
day-to-day basis
and that it's despite the delta variant
still being the chief variant in sweden
just like it is
everywhere else so are the masks the
solution
okay the vaccination is the solution
guys vaccination is the solution
masks were never going to be the
solution and that's why it was so absurd
when you saw people in the federal
government telling you
that you should rely more on your mask
than on vaccinations that the masks
were literally robert redfield said this
in senate testimony he said
masks protect you better than the
vaccine which is just crazy that's just
crazy towns
okay also when it comes to mass mandates
these these have not been successful
nearly anywhere there is no evidence
that mass mandates
right i'm not saying masks mask mandates
government top down directives that you
must wear a mask that these have done
anything no matter to dramatically
decrease either transmission rates
or hospitalization rates or death rates
i'll give you that data in just one
moment first
let's talk about the fact that you
probably have a lot of equity in your
home right it's probably the chief
holder
of your equity at this point your home
mortgage so how much equity do you have
like fifty thousand or a hundred
thousand more
cyber crime experts are learning
homeowners the more equity you have the
greater the chance foreign and domestic
criminals will come after you
home title theft is one of the fastest
growing crimes in the united states in
fact
home title lock america's leader in home
title protection is alerting homeowners
they could already be a victim and you
could not know it
so here's how all of this works first a
cyber thief will search hundreds of
public databases for high equity homes
next they pull your home's online title
forged your signature stating you sold
your home
and take out loans using your equity
you're not covered by insurance your
bank or common identity theft
programs i mean you wouldn't leave like
all of your jewelry just out on the
counter for somebody to steal you
wouldn't leave the front door of your
house on last why would you leave all
the value in your home
open to the world protect your most
valuable asset register your address
right now
see if you're already a victim receive a
complete title history of your home
a 100 value for free go to home title
lock
dot com again that is home title lock
see if you've already become a victim
and then protect yourself
hometitlelock.com
alrighty so you've seen members of the
media who are in full scale panic mode
say that the solution to this is new
mask mandates force all the vaccinated
to masks that they don't breathe or
cough
even asymptomatically on people who are
unvaccinated which again is really
stupid for a variety of reasons
including the fact it makes unvaccinated
people
feel more protected than they actually
are when the actual solution for them
is to go get vaccinated but for example
mika is
uber mads at governor ron desantis in
florida because desantis has said he's
not in favor of mass mandates and he's
not in favor of masking children
in schools here's mika brzezinski going
nuts onto santas
what is going on in florida i know
governor ron desantis
supports the vaccine but this masking
non-mandate or whatever you want to call
it seems very counter to the science
and also we've had a governor who's been
flouting fouchy making fun of uh you
know
the top doctor in the united states i i
feel like he's sending a very mixed
message
to his constituents at what point is the
florida government
liable for what is happening in florida
okay um no he's not sending a mixed
message the message he has been sending
consistently and openly is that there's
a high likelihood you're going to get
coveted
and either you're going to get it or
you're going to get vaccinated that is
the message that rhonda sanchez has been
sending which is why the vaccination
rates
in florida have been rising continuously
florida ranks somewhere in the middle of
the pack in terms of vaccinations but
florida has
already vaccinated all of the olds in
florida which is a lot of people
in florida by the way dr michael
osterholm who is a who is a
an advisor he's a coveted advisor to joe
biden he came out yesterday he said
cloth face masks aren't effective at
delta variant
okay i wonder if he's going to get
banned from youtube for pointing this
out
we know today that many of the face
cloth coverings that people wear
are not very effective in reducing any
of the virus movement in or out
either you're breathing out or you're
breathing in and in fact if you're in
the upper midwest right now anybody
who's wearing their face cloth covering
can tell you
they can smell all the smoke that we're
still getting we need to talk about
better
masking we need to talk about n95
respirators which would do a lot
for both people who are not yet
vaccinated or not previously infected
protecting them
as well as keeping others who might
become infected
having been vaccinated from from
breathing out the virus okay so by the
way if we're going to talk about n95
masks then what we really should be
talking about right now is everybody go
back to normal except people who are
particularly vulnerable
and can't get the vaccine right people
who have serious underlying conditions
you should have the n95s
but you know they're still calling for
mass mandates is the point like broad
mass mandates by the way again
the record on mass mandate sucks it's
really bad like here for example is a
chart from austria
you can see austria started requiring
masks fairly early on in the pandemic
this had been like march
of 2020. they started requiring it after
they had their spike
things remained low then they got to
winter the mass mandate was still in
place boom
huge spike germany same exact thing
germany you can see they put in their
mass mandate
mid mid april of last year they were
already on the downside of the mountain
things remain low boom fall spike same
thing in france
they had like a mild uptick and then a
mild downtick in terms of uh coveted
cases
per million they implemented a mass
mandate in may
fall boom spike same thing in spain i
mean over and over it's the same exact
same exact pattern spain britain belgium
wherever there was a mask requirement it
was usually done after there was already
the major spike
and then afterward there was another
major spike so the notion that you can
just have government tell people to mask
up and this is going to prevent kovid
the the record on that is really really
poor again that is not saying that masks
are completely ineffective although
again there is a wide variation between
cloth masks on small children which is
what most
little kids are wearing which again i
failed to see how any studies that
suggest that that is wildly effective
for for small children
and n95s on adults and my wife as a
doctor was trained in the use of ppe
personal protective equipment were you
and and by the way in the hospital when
you're working with severely ill
patients who have very transmissible
diseases you use an n95
you don't use a surgical mask you don't
you may use a facial
you don't use a you don't use a cloth
mask but
people have started treating the masks
as sort of a totem of religious
iconography
which is at least it was sort of
somewhat understandable on an emotional
level when there were no solutions now
there's a vaccine
there's no rationale for treating masks
as the be all end-all at this point okay
but
the panic continues it pays so here's
the thing
the public health establishment needs
another reason why we need to have the
shutdowns
and centralization of power in the
bureaucracy because
if what i'm saying is true namely adults
are adults and adults get to make adult
decisions and there's a solution right
here and if you don't want to use the
solution
that one's on you which means public
health experts are now basically back to
what they were before
which is they go back to their
laboratories and they go back to their
organizations and they leave the rest of
us to hell alone
they have to have some way of
forestalling their return to anonymity
the way that they forestall the return
to anonymity is they do what they've
been doing
sporadically throughout the pandemic
they say it's about the kids
it is not about the kids the data on the
delta variant demonstrate this thing is
more transmissible there's
no data whatsoever suggesting at this
point data not anecdotal stories
data suggesting that delta is more
deadly for kids can you know who says
this
the washington post there's a good
article in the week just last week
about the risk to children from the
delta variant
professor emily oster has said exactly
the same thing professor of economics
over at brown university she points out
that for children there's higher kid
infection but the risk of serious
disease remains very low you know who
else is saying this dr marcela nunez
smith
who again is a doctor inside the biden
administration she says
kids are not being harmed by delta in
large numbers
thankfully for children the
risk of severe covid um remains still
very small the risk of hospitalization
remains very minimal
death even for the complication people
might know is uh misc
but again you know your parent and so am
i um
every sort of case that can be prevented
we want to prevent
okay so she is herself admitting that
there's no data to suggest this thing is
highly deadly for small children and yet
the kids as always are being used as the
excuse
for more top down public health control
so for example
you have a doctor on cnn on msnbc
guy named red leonard the irwin redlener
who's saying we haven't done enough to
protect kids in schools we haven't done
enough we need to do more to protect
kids in schools
kids in schools were never the main
vector of transmission particularly kids
under the age of 12. by the way in the
united states
emergency use authorization has been
extended for every single person above
the age of 12 in the united states this
is true internationally as well
small children are never they've never
been the main vectors of transmission
small children are not dying from the
virus in any sort of
statistically significant numbers the
number of children who have died without
any pre-existing conditions
from the virus is so low it beggars
imagination
in fact there was a johns hopkins study
recently and it found
i believe zero covert deaths among
healthy young children
hey that like thank god thank god for
that but that's not stopping people
from freaking out because again the
politicians the incentive structure in
our society is so loaded against people
allowing you freedom
if you're a politician and you are
active and intervening in somebody's
life
even if the intervention is stupid and
counterproductive and makes your life
worse
then we give the politicians credit for
trying
okay that is precisely the opposite of
what we should be doing with our
politicians politicians should be given
credit for leaving us the hell alone
and only intervening when necessity
calls for it necessity does not call for
this
but people are so reliant on the
government playing big brother and
playing god
i have to say there's an almost
religious quality to what people want
from their government actors at this
point
there's a religious quality to how
people treat anthony fouchy and there's
a religious quality to help people treat
the government
in general death is coming the
government will save me
covet is it could you know i know that
it's really not damaging the kids i know
that the
the masking procedures they are
recommending are not going to be
particularly effective
but at least they're doing something at
least they're doing something the
government cannot protect you from life
that is not the government's job the
government is designed to protect you
from externalities that are created by
other people acting
in dangerous and irresponsible fashion
that is not the same thing
as you have the ability to protect
yourself now this the game fundamentally
changed when vaccines became available
period end of story nonetheless you have
dr redliner saying kids are at risk kids
are not at serious risk of covid
we have known this for a year children
are at risk garrett and they will be
continuing to be at risk and maybe
greater risk than they are right now so
rsv is a
virus that causes a very common virus
that causes respiratory illness in
children and before the uh pandemic we
would see a lot of this in
in very young children now we're seeing
a rise
in the rsv it's called respiratory
sensational virus we're seeing a rise in
that along with a rise
in covey cases among children this does
not portend very well for what's going
to happen when we start opening schools
and have of course children all over the
country going back into the classroom
without necessarily even mandating that
teachers and other adult workers in
schools uh
get vaccinated okay by the way um rsv is
a different vibration covered
rsv is a different virus than covet so
we're seeing an rsv spike
and we're using that to now suggest that
we need to lock down on the basis of
covet it is a different
virus so
like this is just madness it's just
madness
and and all of this is is driving
government actors who are more activists
to say yeah you know we've got to mask
up our kids we need to mask the data on
masking kids
is nil okay in many countries they don't
mask kids
the notion that masking kids has ever
been highly protective of the
surrounding society
is ridiculous and yet governor mike
dewine of ohio he gets points for
for trying because he says that we
should mask up kids at schools
tell you what we have done we came out
last week
with recommendations there are
recommendations we leave it up to the
local schools
600 some local schools we leave it up to
them but we have a strong recommendation
that because the population in school
kids in school most of them are
unvaccinated
you know obviously we can't get anybody
11 and under vaccinated yet
so most these kids are unvaccinated and
we had great success last
last winter last school year we saw
virtually no spread in the classroom
when all the kids were wearing masks so
we recommend
strong recommendations to our schools
that they do that now some will do that
some will not but it's clear the
evidence shows that that's a way to
really slow down
spread in the school and we think it's
very important okay
is that what the evidence shows because
we've been operating on the basis of
almost no evidence
with regard to public health measures
since the beginning of this pandemic to
take the most obvious example we still
have governors
and senators and public health officials
saying that we need a social distance at
six feet apart
do you know where six feet apart came
from i don't you know who else doesn't
the cdc they've been asked directly
where the six foot guidance comes from
and the answer is nowhere
literally nowhere okay the who has been
saying that three-foot
minimums were the standard this is as of
last year
they were saying a three-foot standard
was the minimum because there were
studies
that were like 100 years old about
droplets there's only one problem
this virus is not a droplet-driven virus
it is aerosolized it's in the air
once you speak it is out there there's
studies suggesting that if you really
want to socially distance from somebody
with covid you need about 30 feet
30 not six so we've been operating on
the basis of just bad data throughout
this entire pandemic
and it just feels like immature people
grasping at straws to try and control
things
that they frankly cannot control very
well
and now in the middle of the thing you
get it again in the middle of the thing
when you are grasping it straws you get
it but i'll tell you when i don't get it
i don't get it when the solution is
there
and when everybody's had the opportunity
to avail themselves of the solution and
people are still
insisting on this crap now there are
people who are taking advantage right
randy weingarten over the american
federation of teachers who's
more one of the more malevolent forces
in american public life
she's already signaling that the schools
might shut down again
because the chief goal of so many of
these teachers unions is to make sure
their teachers never have to do a jot or
tittle of work here is randy weingarten
one of the worst people in the united
states
schools will be open they need to be
open
we need to make sure that they are safe
and healthy
the next question about will they stay
open
that's where we worry because
when you have lots of kids particularly
every
child under 12 has not been vaccinated
we see the delta variant being very
transmissible
so what so what
if a bunch of five-year-olds give each
other the delta variant and they all get
cold
guess what that's called being five have
you ever had a five-year-old okay i have
two kids
who are between the ages of five and
eight and i have a one and a half year
old the one and a half year old has
basically never been sick because she's
never seen human society because of
covid the other two
and that's not by choice now she's out
there and she's circulating and all this
and she gets a cold every so often
because kids
are just petri dishes i don't care if my
five-year-old gets a cold
i don't care if my seven-year-old gets a
cold no parent cares about this
this is this bizarre idiotic notion that
kids are never going to get sick again
and that randy weingarten is deeply
worried for your child unless they're
vaccinated against a disease
that's who date has killed 340 people
under the age of 18 and those are the
cdc stats
yesterday and apparently according johns
hopkins zero of those kids
were perfectly healthy at the time when
they got covered
she is saying that we're going to shut
down schools again
the level of control that unelected
bureaucrats want to hold over your life
is
unending and that's why they need an
unending pandemic we'll get to more of
this
in just one second because again there
are exceptions to every rule the
exceptions are that the specials
themselves don't have to follow any of
the rules we'll get to that in a moment
first
this past weekend you saw that there
were vaccine passport protests in berlin
they turned violent when police decided
to start batoning
women and children the media have turned
a blind eye i haven't seen that covered
very much why well it hurts the
narrative that they have been spinning
which is that the only thing that
matters is the lockdowns okay
authoritarianism has been on the move
you're seeing it from the government
you're seeing it from public health
experts you're seeing it
in your corporate life right where your
boss is telling you what to think and
what to believe
you're seeing it at your schools where
your schools are telling your kids
that they have to believe that america
is a terrible place and that based on
their color they're
they're steeped in the sins of the past
and this is why you need to pick up a
brand new copy of my new book
the authoritarian moment the book does a
deep dive into the history
of authoritarianism in the united states
how it is creeping into our own
government
what we can do to stop it it looks at
every institution in the united states
and looks at how the left renormalize
those institutions and weaponize them
against you in order to reverse that you
have to understand how we got here
the authoritarian moment details that
and more importantly how we stop
it it has an actual action plan in the
authoritarian moment about how to stop
what is going on right now the
authoritarian moment it is now available
at amazon barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller go get your copy right
now
leave a five star review let others know
the book is worth their time
thank you if you want to know what it's
like to be in the presence of the always
trending candace zones it's another day
i believe she's trying again you are now
in luck you can now enter to win a free
trip to meet her and be part of her live
studio audience if you sign up now as a
daily wire member with code vip
you get 25 to offer your new membership
and you're automatically entered for a
chance to win
a trip for two to the daily wire studios
to see candace live
not only will you be meeting candace
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio
front row seats watch her destroy the
left's insidious ideology on her brand
new talk show candace it's a good time
on candace's set this isn't an
opportunity i'd pass up
were i you so if you're in the mood for
a vacation with a side of leftist
takedowns
go now to win two vip tickets to kansas
at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 25 off
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
so this is not none of this none of the
realities are stopping
people on the left from engaging in a
sort of full-scale hypocrisy so
you have andrew cuomo in new york who
killed all the old people in new york
which is you know
pretty amazing that he's still the
governor and apparently no one cares
remember that time when he was embroiled
in all these sexual harassment scandals
and then those just kind of went away
because he's a democrat yeah that was
fun anyway andrew cuomo
he said yesterday that private
businesses should ban the unvaccinated
which is unbelievably stupid again these
are all public health measures that are
likely to achieve the opposite
of what people who are pushing them
supposedly want to achieve if you push
all of the unvaccinated into one area
and you push all the vaccinated
into the other area which is what andrew
cuomo is now proposing
what do you suppose happens inside the
unvaccinated area
you think things spread slower or faster
the answer is a lot faster if you want a
higher case count make sure that you
separate the vaccinated from the
unvaccinated
that's precisely what andrew cuomo is
pushing because once again
our politics reward people for doing
something
even if that something is setting your
hair on fire and then running directly
into a tree
you get rewarded for that in politics so
long as you're doing something
if you just say listen not much we can
do here live your life be on your own
then the media are like
how dare you watch let people die
death sound days here's andrew cuomo
setting his hair on fire and then
running directly into a tree
private businesses i am asking
them and suggesting to them
go to vaccine only admission
go to vaccine-only admission
oh well um you know if they do that then
that would probably fix everything
except for how it's not going to the
good news is that if you're a
high-profile democrat you don't have to
pay attention to any of this so here is
cnn's
john berman defending maskless mural
bowser
attending a wedding so that it's good
times if you're muriel bowser
you are so special the rules don't apply
to you this has been true throughout the
pandemic right
if you're a chris cuomo you don't have
to pay attention to quarantine rules and
if you're lori lightfoot then you get to
go get your hair done and if you're
nancy pelosi you get to do the same
thing
the rules just don't apply to you you're
one of the special people here is cnn's
john berman
defending muriel bowser attending a
wedding at masklas indoors
we were criticizing politicians for
wearing masks
still where the science was telling them
oh
they didn't need to be you know we kept
on asking the white house why is joe
biden still wearing a mask
when the mass guidance you know has
changed and now of course we're saying
she should be wearing a mask even though
she was still following the guidance
look
i i get it if you're a politician you
don't want a picture that raises
questions that's bad politics the
question is
you know whether or not she did anything
functionally policy wise wrong
and i don't know well you know i mean we
were yes
it's her standard she's the one who just
put a mask math date in place
again all of this is about control it's
it is incredible
how all of the right-wing fears about
people taking advantage of a pandemic to
grab control
have now been basically justified and
this is coming from somebody
who again was perfectly willing to
suspend judgments on that particular
question when we didn't know anything
about the virus
and i didn't say that people shouldn't
wear masks i was not rapidly anti-mask
i i didn't say at any point that people
shouldn't take vaccines i've been
rabidly pro-vaccine
but the point here is that now they're
still grabbing power
this is an amazing it really is a
low-key amazing story that people are
just ignoring
so according usa today the cdc has now
extended a policy that allows migrants
to be expelled over coveted concerns
so the biden administration wants to
reject all of donald trump's immigration
policies
they've done that on the southern border
and we've gotten an unprecedented flood
of people
washing across the border and citing joe
biden's policy as a rationale
so that's a bad headline they don't
really want to openly walk back their
own border policies
so instead they've now empowered the cdc
to do it for them
we have giant bureaucracies who are
simply empowered to do the thing that
the president kind of wants to be done
but he doesn't have to do it in a way
that he's answerable for so the biden
administration extended a trump era
policy on monday
that allows migrants to be expelled to
prevent the spread of covet 19 in
holding facilities
i'm sure that part of this by the way
was a bunch of pictures that were coming
out of those holding facilities in which
thousands of coveted positive people
were waiting in lines and then reports
that a lot of those people were just
being released into the interior of the
united states
the cdc said in a statement the title 42
quote shall remain in effect
until the cdc director determines that
the danger of further introduction of
covet 19 into the united states from
covered non-citizens has ceased to be a
serious danger to public health
and the order is no longer necessary to
protect the public health title 42
allows cbp that's customs and border
protection
to expel undocumented migrants to
prevent the spread of coven 19 in
holding facilities some children and
families are exempt
from the policy dhs said in a statement
title 42 is not an immigration authority
but a public health authority
and its continued use is dictated by cdc
and governed by the cdc's analysis of
public health factors
okay i was not so let's just get this
straight over the course of the pandemic
the cdc which again stands for centers
for disease control
has now been put in charge for purposes
of centralizing power
of federal eviction moratoriums which
again they have no
constitutional or statutory power to do
they do not have the power to simply
reject
the ability of land of homeowners to
collect rent
and apartment owners to collect rent no
one gave the cdc that authority they
just took it
the cdc does not have plenary power over
immigration apparently they now have
been given
plenary power over immigration and now
they are doing this in the midst
of what is a non-crisis we do not have a
crisis in this country
the unvaccinated have made a decision
not to be vaccinated
i can't say this enough times okay a
crisis requires two things
one a bad thing to happen and two for
that thing to be relatively
unpreventable
what is happening right now is not only
not unpreventable
it has largely been prevented by the
vast vaccination of the american
population
and yet we're still doing this routine
and so
like i really wonder if amer there's so
many americans who apparently are just
willing to give up their freedom on the
basis of
pretty much nothing nothing the entire
population of san francisco apparently
is going to go along with masking up
despite a seven day
running death average of zero apparently
washington dc
gonna do the same thing they have a
running day seven day death average
in washington dc of zero and they're all
masking up again
and so this does lead me to wonder in a
very serious way
what is the future of this country
seriously what is the future of this
country
because so long as you can sufficiently
scare people you can get them to give
any amount of power to the government
apparently
endless amounts of power to the
government you can imagine a situation
in which a few years from now the the
weather continues to to
get wonky out there because we are
experiencing yes
a warming of the globe that is going to
take place over the course of the next
century
and human beings have an extraordinary
capacity to adapt
but you can see our political boss is
saying disaster will strike
and you and your family will die unless
we lock you in your house for three
months a year without air conditioning
right
like what will people be willing to do
what sort of inconvenience
will they be willing to to go along with
in order to prevent the slightest chance
of a bad thing happening
we used to be a rather hardy people
liberty seeking people and i wonder
whether we are now two peoples one group
of people who are willing to undertake
risk
rational risk and one group of people
who are utterly unwilling to countenance
any risk and are willing to give
unending power to a centralized
authority to prevent themselves from
even having to make the decision
that's the question on my mind these
days already we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of the
benjamin shapiro show coming up soon the
matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm eastern
be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina her
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show
morning wire on today's episode an
olympic update
the eviction moratorium expires and the
taliban seizes control of half of
afghanistan
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire